moi je suis dit je suis en désaccord
avec ceux avec cette analyse je
considère que une droitisation que je
pourrais qualifier de super structurel
c'est à dire au niveau de la parole
politique de la parole médiatique ça je
pense qu'on peut tous accordé juste à
regarder la gueule des médias de plus en
plus une chaîne comme ces news qui pour
moi est la pointe avancée de ce discours
réactionnaire derrière bolloré ce qu'il
a fait à europe 1 avec presque 300
journalistes qui ont dû quitter le
navire en fait pour mettre à la place
des sonia mabrouk des coq etc je suis à
l'europe où j'étais avant je suis tout
je vous ai toujours vous savez même pas
que vous m'aimez génocidaire mais bon
l'émission n'a pas changé c'est vrai
mais vous n'êtes dernier des mohicans
la réalité c'est que dans dans les
médias et dans la parole politique il ya
une droitisation et ça vient même pas
spécialement que de l'extrême droite
quand vous avez arnaud montebourg je
considère pas qu'arnaud montebourg est
un est un fou ou qu'il a un moment donné
il a eu un moment d'absence je pense que
c'est calculé lorsqu'il le fait sa
sortie sur les transferts d'argent vers
les pays qui acceptent pas de récupérer
les immigrés en occuper h je considère
qu il sait ce qu'il fait lorsque roussel
va manifester avec zemmour bardella
philippot etc les cinq abc avec les
policiers avec les syndicats de
policiers mais tout en sachant ce qui
fait je considère que lorsqu'il a fait
une sortie en disant que ceux qui n'ont
pas vocation à rester légalement sur le
territoire doivent repartir chez eux
c'est aussi et c'est assez terrible donc
je pense que il ya une droitisation à
tous niveaux mais je considère cependant
qu'il ya une gauchisation si je peux
dire de cette manière là de la société
des idées qui est assez incroyable en
fait
[Musique]